this morning we have a first look at the
most essential guitar from Pink Floyd's
David Gilmour Rolling Stone calls him
one of the greatest guitarists all-time
no argument there Gilmour is selling
more than 120 of his personal guitars
through Christie's auction house they
include the iconic Fender Stratocaster
known as the black strat Gilmour bought
it in 1970 and played it on Pink Floyd's
best-known albums of the 70s 80s and 80s
from Dark Side of the Moon to the wall
[Music]
my dream and ambition was to have a
fender
you know preferably a Stratocaster I
loved it from the beginning Buddy Holly
played one Hank Marvin played one that
was enough for me I just wanted a strat
but shine on you crazy diamond came out
of this guitar in one way or another is
probably on most tracks from 1970
through till the middle ages and we are
lucky enough to have the black strat
with us here in studio 57 Christie's
musical instruments consultant in
private sales expert Carrie keen is also
here Carrie good morning I can't touch
it can I just gonna do that very
important instrument it is without a
doubt yeah I mean there's not many
guitars electric guitars out there that
that are as iconic and connected to a
performer as important as David Gilmour
so how do you how much do you think it's
gonna go for Oh everyone asked that
question I wish I had the crystal ball
yeah
there are a few pinch marks we have
estimated it very similar to what we
estimated Blackey which was Eric
Clapton's guitar in 2004 one hundred two
hundred fifty thousand that guitar with
premium did nine hundred and sixty-five
thousand yeah but for that amount of
money David Gilmour apparently says he
wants people to actually continue
playing the guitar he does absolutely
wonderful this is not a precious item to
David Gilmour it's a tool of the trade
it's it's it's the paintbrush for the
painter yeah certainly without and he
and he wants them to continue to make
music he bought it in 1970 at Manny's
guitar shop here in New York on music
row right now 48th Street because these
previous one had been stolen correct yes
yes so and played it almost right away
was the first performance with first
performance oh I wish my colleague from
London was here to nail down that date I
believe it was a festival in about 1971
I think in bath it was right and he's
selling it for charity I mean he's
really trying to raise money it's a
wonderful mission and
he has a great passion for this
philanthropic mission great supporter of
homeless issues and and hunger and this
is where he wants the proceeds for this
sale of these I I was struck by how
unsentimental he was about this yes I'm
so willing perfectly happy to part with
these that it's basically done its job
I'm ready to move on I have other strats
you know but given given all that he
wrote with it I was I was just struck by
that it if everyone has said the same
thing that's the refrain how can you
give this up um there was one guitar in
the cell and it was a it's a 1969
Martin d-35 which from the very first
conversations I had with him he said I'm
not sure I'm letting this one go he
didn't make the decision until October
of last year and he said okay I'm ready
we should say there are how many guitars
in all are there in this sale 126 Wow
and 26 that's the normal number of a
artist like this yes good question yes
it is I mean there again they're tools
of the trade
musicians are constantly looking for
that different sound that different
tonality tambour and they're always
reaching for it this is a great example
David Gilmour from day one started
altering the guitar and we can see where
he had cut out holes inside and he put
in a he put in a new jack he which has
now been filled he put a new tail piece
in the very first alteration he made on
this guitar was with the switch in 1969
you know the fender only had a 3-way
switch we could play that pick up the
middle pickup or the bridge pickup he
wanted to play these two the bridge and
the neck no Fender guitar could do that
he took a little piece of metal he bent
it he pulled the switch out and he made
a contact Wow
so the only thing you didn't change was
the color correct yeah thank you very
much for walking us through it I know
it'll go to the highest bidder but I
hope that bidder is someone who intends
to play it
very much thanks for coming that's great